we're here at the wired party taking a
step back to see what we've seen on the
show floor this week at the consumer
electronics show
now 2011 was an interesting year for 3d
technology especially as it pertains to
televisions
but 2012 i think is going to be a make
or break here now personally i like 3d
technology i think it really pops i
think it's very dynamic for the content
especially for sports and other uh
movies but uh
it's it's it's reassuring to see that
the tech manufacturers are not backing
away they're actually super committed to
3d and you see that
being adopted into super high end
screens such as those with oled and
ultra definition
resolution so while there were some
strides made in 2011
2012 is definitely going to have to see
a lot more progress in order for 3d
technology to stick around